era una mañana normal en Japón hasta que
ocurrió esto
tenemos noticias de última hora el
gobierno japonés advierte que Corea del
Norte parece haber lanzado al menos un
misil balístico existe la posibilidad de
que se dirija a Japón el gobierno está
llamando a todos en el país a permanecer
en el interior o encontrar un refugio
inmediatamente
en todo Japón en pequeños pueblos y
grandes ciudades sonaron las sirenas
[Música]
junto con un mensaje ominoso
un misil ha sido lanzado Corea del Norte
parece haber lanzado un misil
mensajes de advertencia llegaron a los
teléfonos los trenes de alta velocidad
se detuvieron abruptamente con el mismo
mensaje repetido en bucle
[Música]
se dio el visto bueno unos 20 minutos
después el misil cayó en el Pacífico
pero el daño estaba hecho el país estaba
sacudido y enfadado
vivo en un apartamento Así que no tengo
sótano cuando me dijeron que me pusiera
cubierto bajo tierra mi reacción sincera
fue realmente no sé qué hacer aunque no
haya sanciones quiero que el gobierno
adopte una postura más firme frente a
Corea del Norte
[Música]
me sentía asustada si su tecnología ha
mejorado significa que están trabajando
en ello a diario Me preocupa que algún
día puedan fabricar un misil potente
fue la primera vez que un misil
norcoreano sobrevoló Japón desde 2017
las autoridades calificaron en el
disparo como un acto imprudente y
dijeron que la distancia de vuelo
estimada de este misil en particular Era
la más larga entre los cohetes lanzados
anteriormente